[Music]
hello everybody thank you for being here
it's a pleasure Priya and I are really
excited to talk smart case routing
systems with you today it's a
combination of some of the the better
techniques that we've encountered the
better approaches the better the best
tools and also lessons we've learned
from building case routing systems and
natural language processing through the
years at Springer Mel let me look at the
agenda here we're gonna start by
introducing ourselves spring ml in case
routing briefly then we're gonna tackle
the the meat of the matter
the three main models that that that
build this smart case routing system and
finally we'll open up for questions and
and we'll also be around afterwards if
you have additional questions so let's
pretend ourselves do want to start for
you yes sure hi everyone I'm Priya dyd
I'm a data scientist at Spring ml I've
been a spring ml for about six months
prior to joining spring ml I work for
Capital One for about ten years I'm very
passionate about deep learning and I've
been working through it for the last
three years I also write blogs very
frequently and you can find me on medium
thank you
I'm - manual immunity guy and I'm also a
data scientist I'm the VP of data
science at Spring ml and I've been at
spring about practically since the
beginning I think a few months shy since
the company was created about three
three years ago and I also AM so prior
to that I was a data scientist in
healthcare for four years and prior to
that a quantitative developer on Wall
Street for six years and I'm very
passionate and interested about applied
data science I'd like to see how we we
take these all these models that are
coming our way every day and see how we
can apply them to make our lives to
everyday life easier right so of course
curing cancer would be great right but
it's it's not an easy thing to tackle
but like cased routing these kind of
things we have the tools today to do it
and to do it well so that's very
exciting so briefly about spring ml
we're a company that brings AI and
machine learning to companies who either
don't have the staff the department and
know-how or need extra hands
and we will kind of take a step back
with them look at what they're trying to
do look at their data if it can be
achieved and then dive in with them as a
team so that we work in tandem and that
they have a sense of ownership and then
they can take it on they can extend it
and they can sell it internally if need
be and we're also happy to form longer
term relationships I mentioned that we
build quite a few case routing systems
and that's true over the years we've
built them and it was what's interesting
about a case writing and natural
language processing in general is that
his has evolved enormously what we're
gonna present today is very different
than what we started actually there's
probably a very little that intersects
and we we've done a lot of case routing
demos internally we've done them for
Google and we've also a partnered with
Google for other customers the biggest
customer we worked with the CBRE it's a
very large commercial real estate
company they're all around the world and
you can imagine the flurries of case of
cases going back and forth issues
questions comments so you could have on
one end you know please change in this
country change the light bulb here there
you can have always a great investment
opportunity there or you know here
there's a building that's flooded you
know we need the basement is flooded we
need you know to call the maintenance
crew so all these things go back and
four sisters in a very large company so
automating case routing for companies at
that size but even smaller companies is
a huge win that's what we're gonna talk
about today so that we're all on the
same page what is case routing so case
routing is whenever you have a
department a team or even a single
person that that is in charge of taking
you know either external queries or
questions or internal ones and routing
them case routing right routing them to
where they need to go in some cases they
can even answer them right and I don't
know show of hands who's been on call
with their job yeah I wasn't caught when
I was in healthcare I wasn't a call and
it was really tough job very stressful
because I remember like health care
never sleeps machines go down on the
weekend or at night and I wouldn't you
know I wouldn't know who to turn to
where to get help but people I would
normally ask help they were either
sleeping or playing golf right so it was
it was very stressful and and that's why
I having a personal agenda to work on
this to fix this this issue and why
would you want to
made this well you know the obvious
reasons what you're removing that middle
layer like the people on call like me
who don't want to be on call you're
removing that and the customer or the
client - what would the employee who has
a question they know that's gonna go to
the right Department immediately you get
24/7 support you can handle multiple
languages right we model this in English
but you can very well model in any
language you want so once you have one
language down it's just a question of
getting enough historical data to model
other languages you have you can do auto
reply right very simple order replies
like somebody saying when is when is the
office open and you say oh this country
has a national holiday try this you know
this state what is that easy wins you
could automate that and more important I
think is the centralized digital trail
you're gonna start getting a warehouse
of all your your queries all your
questions and so who who's asking what
type of question where are their
problems
what department tackles those answers
which one are struggling to answer those
questions all that is gold for a company
right you can really learn a lot about
your company about what's going on with
your cost and learning about your
customers as well so these are there's
three main models that we're going to
talk about but basically the brains
behind what we're going to present there
will be a convolutional neural network
that's gonna do the the predicting of
what department to route a case to there
is the language at the Google language
API that we're going to leverage as much
information as we can from from there to
get additional information and finally
finding similar cases so you got a case
that came in you want to know what is a
similar case and how is it resolved
that's great hints for somebody who's
handling that the caseload and as a
high-level architecture before we dive
in into CNN's this is what we this is
what we build in the past this is what
we would build today - you have the
incoming case that comes in and you have
the App Engine so the App Engine is a
service instance in the cloud it's a
great - a great type of instance compute
engine for this type of project
especially if you have cyclical
caseloads right so if you have more
cases during the year these things will
size automatically well what will
balance will will scale and you pay only
for what you use it's also kind of the
the choreographer the the manager of the
data you will do some data cleaning
asset to the the cloud Emily the the
mounted machine learning engine in the
cloud which which is hosting our
convolutional neural network and Priya
will talk more about the data set but
it's about financial consumer complaints
right we're using an open-source data
set and it can route it into one of
seven departments consumer loan vehicle
loan bank at Cameron student loan
mortgage credit card or payday loan so
these departments are all you know
related and all within the financial
industry and so the the CNN what will
tell you what Department to route it to
so now we know where to route it the app
engine will then also pass the
information to the language API where
we're going to get all sorts of
information we can like sentiment we'll
know if it's a the tone of the case
things like the organization involves
and now we can populate that information
in our in our in our case reports and
we're also going to query bigquery with
a huge bottomless data warehouse where I
was reading it can you know it could
query like 35 billion rows and seconds
with no indexes so we're very powerful
tool perfect for you know storing all of
your knowledge base all your cases and
here we're going to pull similar cases
and the end product for the demo is this
this smart report we call it right so it
will tell you what the complaint is give
you some some hints about what's going
on there and some suggestions of how to
resolve it so this is what the demo
right most of the cases we would feed
this directly into the customer's CRM
right they probably have a tool already
so either a rest point or an API right
but for the sake of the demo we wanted
something that was that that was visual
and I'm going to pass it to Priya talk
about the cnn's thanks Manuel so I'm
gonna talk about how we build a
convolutional neural network in
tensorflow to do the case routing so
before I start by show of hands can I
know how many of you have built any kind
of model in tensorflow before okay
that's a lot that's really good to know
I've kept the talk here high level but
if you have any specific questions feel
free to stop me after the talk so the
first thing I want to talk about is the
data set that we used to to build this
model consumer financial protection
bureau in the US has a publicly
available data set of two
74,000 consumer complaints across many
different products like bought cash
credit cards student loans etc when a
consumer complaints to CFPB they have
the option of making their complaint
public and when they decide to do that
any sensitive information like their
names or amounts or dates are naanum
eyes and this data is publicly available
we think this is a really good data set
for deep learning because it's pretty
big there's a huge variety here it uses
natural language and what I mean by that
is if you actually read through the
complaints you'll see that some
companies are very long some are shard
their spelling mistakes some consumers
repeat themselves so it's it's perfect
to use that for deep learning I also
feel that the database is very rich in
financial terms so it's possible to
actually use this data set for other use
cases like routing customer service
calls so now now that we have the data
set you can think of this data set as
you know individual complaints and
complaints can be long or short so I've
taken a sample complaint here that says
you decline my transaction when I was
shopping and this is all words but
neural networks love numbers and maths
so we do pre processing that converts
these sentences into numbers the first
thing we do is we break the sentence
into individual words and so that would
be you decline my transaction etc and
then we map these words into integers so
we could say that you corresponds to 23
and decline corresponds to 45 and so on
and this can be arbitrary you know you
can choose any of them you just need to
save this mapping for later so if you
want to convert the integers back
towards you can do that so now we have
you know our complaints represented as
integers so when we feed them into the
neural network we have to assign a
tensor to hold them and it's tensorflow
likes the tensors to be fixed size so
you can specify them them in advance so
this means that it would like all
complaints to be of the same length but
in your data set different complaints
can be different lengths so to solve
this we we choose a length and then we
so everything is it's that line so if
it's longer than that we truncate it if
it's shorter than that then we pad it so
let's say in this hypothetical example
we want everything to be twelve words
long so this is four short so we add
four zeros at the end which correspond
to a pad token in the model but just for
reference you know the actual actual
data set was much longer so the
complaints were were padded to 600 words
ok so awesome and so as you know after
this point we have you know our data set
is all complaints of same then all of
them represented by integers but if you
think about it all these integers are
unique like so we have all words
represented uniquely but that's not
really how our languages words are not
unique ones are related to each other
some words are synonyms some are
antonyms some words are very likely to
be in similar contexts for example a
king and queen are very likely to be
talked about in the same context much
more so than king and aii right so to
get over that or to give the model our
understanding of English language we
convert each word into a vector and this
can be you know a vector of any size we
ended up using 128 dimensional vector
and so what happens is that words that
are similar or are likely to occur in
similar contexts have word vectors that
are closer to each other in the vector
space and so this allows us to give the
model understanding of semantics so to
train these word vectors we can use two
techniques we can train these word
vectors as part of training the neural
networks so we initialize them randomly
and then we back use back propagation to
train them as we you know build the
model and that's what we did in this
case and this allows the vectors to have
understanding of financial terms the
other way is that you can actually use
pre trained word vectors and these are
available on the Internet I think love
is a good source of these pre trained
vectors and these pre-trained vectors
have been trained on huge corpus of you
know English language like Wikipedians
and stuff so they are also good at
generally understanding what context
words are used in so Manuel will later
show you scales way
use the pre-trained word vectors okay so
now we have you know we took our
complain and we converted everything
into numbers so we're good to use a
neural network so in this case we build
a CNN for text classification I think a
lot of you might have heard of CNN's
they have been quite popular in computer
vision they have been used very
successfully on images for detection
tracking classification etc but more
recently CNN's have actually been used
very successfully for text
classification as well and this might
sound a little bit unintuitive so part
of the goal of this slide for me is to
actually explain to you the architecture
on a high level and also give some
intuition around why this actually works
so maybe let's start with a small
sentence here I like this movie very
much so this is seven words and each
word is represented by a five
dimensional word vector so you can think
of this as a seven by five matrix and at
this point you can see that's somehow
like an image because it becomes 2d and
then we choose different filters so we
choose filters of size two words three
words and four words and they're
represented by different colors here
these filters will do the convolution
operation on the sentence one way of
thinking about this convolution
operation is the filter of two words
will look at two adjacent words three
words will look at three words and then
four would look at four and so this is
kind of like a bag of words so the
neural network is trying to look at
adjacent words and trying to extract
meaning from the sentence and then it
creates these feature maps which are
these one-dimensional vectors that have
summarized everything and you can see
them as different vectors of different
colors here and then finally since all
of these feature maps are different
lengths to actually use them in the
neural network we do sort of like a
hacky fix where we do a 1d max pooling
we take the maximum value from each of
these feature maps and convert combine
them to create this colored vector at
the end so the way I think of all of
this operation is the neural network has
or the CNN has gone over the sentence
and extracted all the relevant
information and combine that into that
colored vector which is the output from
this stage
okay so I want to summarize the model
once more before I move on so we started
with draw text of complaints we did
pre-processing that converted the text
into integers then we converted all the
word integers into word vectors we built
a CNN in our actual CNN we use four
different filter sizes of two words see
words four words and five words we do
the concatenation and then the final
layer in the model is a fully connected
layer with sigmoid activation and what
this does is it it assigns it basically
assigns each complaint into one of the
seven departments assigning them
different probabilities and we can just
pick the department with the highest
probability as the prediction from the
model so as you can see this is a
relatively simple architecture and it's
amazing you know how well this works so
we were able to get 85% accuracy in
correctly predicting Department on the
test set which is which is the set that
the model wasn't exposed to at the time
of training some of other other big
benefits here where the model is
actually quite quick to Train so I took
only about 15 minutes of training time
on a single GPU since it's so quick to
train it's very easy to do tuning of
hyper parameters or testing our
different architectures it transparently
fast at inference time as well so we're
able to use a CPU at inference time and
that's what we will show in the demo as
well right now it can also be retrained
periodically so let's say you rollout
with this model and you use it for three
months and you collect new real data in
the field you can easily plug that back
in and retrain the model and then
finally I think a more subtle but
actually pretty important point is
because this model uses deep learning
you don't really need to do any complex
feature engineering the model itself
extract features which means that you
don't need to be an expert in financial
services and you also don't need to be
an NLP expert to use this this in my
opinion makes deep learning very
versatile where same architecture can be
applied on different problems in
different domains legal in financial
services in you know wherever you want
to apply them okay so
we have talked a lot about the model so
now I want to actually do a demo of it
let's see if I can switch screens okay
this is awesome
so what we did is we designed a web demo
so this demo allows us to interact with
the model more easily so in this first
page of the demo we have the customer's
name phone number and address which is
arbitrary at this point because the
actual data had this information
anonymized and then in this section
right here is where we can put in
complaint and then when we when we run
it this complaint is run against the CNN
at the back so the complaint that I have
chosen is an interesting one it says I'm
in the process of refinancing with
Quicken Loans it's been over 45 days and
I still don't have a closing date they
keep giving me the runaround and it's
been nothing but a headache so what I
personally find interesting about this
complaint is there is no mention of any
department here and it's actually a very
small complaint as well so if you're not
familiar with the financial services
domain it might be hard for you know to
know what product is being talked about
here and and that I think is the full
benefit of deep learning is just by
looking at a whole bunch of complaints
it has understood what are the key terms
involved with each product and it's then
able to use that so now when I hit
submit the neural network runs in the
backend and actually assigns this to the
market department which is correct so
besides actually predicting the
department which is what the case
routing would help with we also have
here what we call the smart report so
this report has a lot of interesting
insights so from the text in the
complaint we are able to create this
word cloud which has the keywords in the
complaint we're also able to give a
sentiment index sentiment score to this
complaint we can extract organizations
and categories that are being talked
about as well as we are able to look
into our historical database for other
similar complaints and present that to
the agent who's actually working this
complaint and that can be pretty useful
right so if you are if you're working
this complaint you might want to know
what what was done in the past and you
can apply a similar resolution so in the
next part of this presentation we want
to go and talk about how we actually
created this smart report switchback
okay so I'm gonna now talk about how we
use the Google language API so before I
start like by show of hands can I know
how many of you have used the Google
language API before okay that's good to
know
so those of you who haven't I would
actually encourage you to try it out
it's pretty simple to use so there is
the the home page for the natural
language API has sort of a section where
you can use it easily you don't really
need to code in Python to do this so
that's what I want to do now is I want
to actually showcase the the web web
page where you can use the language API
so this is you know I click right into
invent into the natural language API
home page and within here there is the
option to try the API so I picked sample
sentence that says ABC Bank has
associated my number with someone else's
delinquent account they're calling me
every hour and will not remove my number
from the other person's account so this
person is clearly stressed so when I hit
analyze essentially what would happen is
that the language API would go and
extract information and share that with
me across four tabs so there's entities
sentiment syntax and categories the
entities portion of the API looks at
things like hey what's an organization
what's a person what's an event and
stuff like that and presents that
information the sentiment sentiment tab
gives me a sentiment score for the
entire text as well as for each
individual sentence so it has correctly
assigned this sentence a slightly
negative sentiment which is true and
then for the each individual sentences
there is a sentiment score what I find
very very interesting here is that if
you look at the second sentence which
says they're calling me every hour and
will not remove my number for
the other person's account there's
actually no real big negative word here
but the model has correctly understood
that the overall sentiment here is
pretty negative and I would have
actually done the same I would have
assigned this sentence a pretty negative
sentiment score so the API also has very
very rich information about syntax so
this has things like part of speech like
what works are now in verbs adverbs etc
it also has dependency map which which
can show you visually how words are
related to each other so you can use
this to very quickly understand what are
the verbs in your sentence and then do
analysis after that and then finally it
also has categories so for us it's very
generic it says these complaints are
related to financial services and
banking which is true but I think this
feature can be very useful if your data
set has complaints of many different
types and then it can actually tell you
what the relevant categories are quite
accurately and it would be useful okay
so now I want to hand it back over to
Manuel who will walk you through how we
use the language API in our demo Thank
You Priya so Priya gave us a good
overview of what the Google language API
is all about and I want to kind of dive
a little bit deeper into how we used it
in the smart report it's a very powerful
tool I think these are pre-trained
models in the cloud so whenever you can
I know use anything that's pre trained
whether an image modeling transfer
learning in in using pre trained word
vectors and NLP or things like tools
like these pre trained models Google
offers many of them not just a language
as vision this video there's translation
there's transcription all sorts of
really cool tools whenever you can push
that work on to other people who
specialized on that it's a win that
allows you to focus you and your team on
the use case on the business use case
and leverage these tools that work
really well and are probably harder for
us to replicate as well and it frees up
a lot of time on our end so the smart
case report this portion of the report
is a fuel despaired by the language API
and I'm gonna walk you through a few
so the the word cloud is interesting
right it's been used a lot in
educational tools but it's also very
powerful in terms of highlighting word
frequencies which words are used the
most is very visual you don't have to
worry too much about a waste present
it's gonna present it for you they'll
show the largest words you know in a
larger font and everything else you know
smaller but it doesn't have to be
frequency it can be anything you want
right you can program this you could do
for example part of speech which priya
was showing us like the action verbs i
want i need you know that would be also
useful in terms of quickly figure out
what a piece of text is about
they're very easy to implement you can
program them in all sorts of languages
through rest calls through through
python it's just a call to the API and
oh and also the sentiment index right
it's a number between I think negative
one and one right and here we presented
in a linear scale with emoticons with
from very unhappy to very happy you know
in in a fraction of a second you quickly
know the tone of the email so very
powerful especially if you're doing
customer service the topics so those
also refer to as categories there is a
category in a subcategory currently
there is I think about last time I read
it about 700 categories it supports in
the financial world does a really good
job at differentiating it because as you
saw our seven departments are pretty
closely related it still tells the
difference between all sorts of things
very powerful and a nice thing about
using the these cloud-based pre-training
models is it's a 700 right now and you
can go to sleep and when you wake up in
the morning suddenly it's a thousand
categories or ten thousand categories
right so you automatically benefit from
better pre trained model without having
to worry about it because you're just
calling the API the organization's also
really cool you'll pull all sorts of
entities that can pull famous famous
locations it can think locations in this
case organizations so really smart to
pull these kind of things and quickly
tell the the person of the agent has
taken care of this who are the major
players in this complaint and now I'll
talk about now pulling similar
complaints that were resolved in the
past so this is this there are different
ways you can approach this problem we
thought we had a pretty clever one here
and the idea is that you know you have
an incoming case and it
in complaint in this in for this data
set and you want to know what is what
happens well what have other agents done
in the past and how have they resolved
it right so not only is that going to be
a lot of help for the for the agent it's
also a step closer to automatic to to
doing auto-replies right once you know
how this works well you can determine
well you know I think it can the the the
the machine learning can handle this
automatically that's just fire off a
reply so you have this original
complaint that comes that imaginary has
20 words right and we want to so it's
hard to you have these 20 words it's
hard to kind of fish in an entire
knowledge base of historical complaints
that we've dealt with in the past and
finding a similar one right so we're
going to do is going to use pre trained
word embedded vectors to boost the
vocabulary right so what is a pre pre I
talked a bit about it what is a you know
pre-trained or D meta vectors so galuf
is a really popular one
they have taken either Wikipedia as a
corpus of the English language or even
common crawl which is like a certain
percentage of the entire Internet and
modeled it to figure out exactly how
each word relates to each other word so
in the end it's very complex modeling so
that's why we're very happy somebody
else did it for us and in the end you
have a matrix with all the the most
commonly spoken English words and a long
array of numbers and these dismembers
for each word represents how one word
relates to another and that's how you
can get the the King to queen is you
know a man to woman it understands that
there's basically a mathematical
underlying to the English language
that's captured in these pre trained
word vectors and if anybody has worked
with word Tyvek and has pre trained
their own corpuses it's not easy it
takes a lot of time you gotta have the
right equipment and you got a tune you
gotta you gotta tune it correctly right
otherwise you got to go back and do
everything I did that lot in healthcare
and it was very uh it was a lot of work
and we didn't have GPUs so it was like
sometimes a week to two weeks of work
right and just to find out that you made
a mistake and you have to do it again
very frustrating so this is phenomenal
that they make these available the glove
is from Stanford I think Stanford and
Glover working together
Stanford is maintaining the glove data
sets and they're open source anybody can
use them so now so what we're doing
we're basically taking every word of
that original complaint let's pretend
there's 20 words and here is a well zoom
into one word the word transaction so
then you can say
using this pre-trained matrix find me
all the words that are close to the word
transaction and because you have this
complex matrix with that represents how
each word relates to air to every other
word you can use any distance metrics
you want Euclidean distance cosine
distance it doesn't matter and you
basically have created a a an electronic
very powerful thesaurus right so instead
of having store transaction you can
boost it to buying business contract
agreement or even a hundreds of words so
you do that for all your important words
not just you know you'll be ignore your
stop words all your important words so
you take that that case I has 20 words
originally now you can have you know ten
thousand words right and you can go
fishing basically a big bag of words and
you can go fishing into your knowledge
base and finding the most related the
closely related cases to bring to the
surface um of course you've got to do a
little you got to weigh the word you can
do a little normalization otherwise the
very large historical cases work would
take precedence and you don't want that
right so there's a little bit more more
work involved but that's the overall
idea so and then so then you basically
would repeat what I just said you're
gonna go with that the huge bag of words
instead of you know twenty now it's a
thousand and pull similar similar cases
so that has three distinct advantages
are pretty pretty pretty powerful for
starters you can now find cases you can
have fun historical cases that don't
intersect I have no word at all
intersecting with your original date the
new incoming case right because you
buffer that with a new vocabulary they
could have no word in common and and you
can still pull them out the second one
is there's no training on our end we're
not modeling this on our end because
we're we're kind of piggybacking on the
pre trained word vectors right so all
that work is pushed on to somebody else
we don't have to do any pre training
that save us a lot of time and the third
advantage which is related to this is
that because we're not doing a pre
training we don't have to waste any of
our own knowledge based data our own
historical case data for training we can
then use the entire corpus to find
similar complaints you can going all the
way from the first complaint ever
entered in your data warehouse to the
word that maybe it was resolved two
seconds ago
if it's similar we can find it and we
can pull it so you have access to your
entire your entire four that's pretty
powerful I'm gonna do a demo as well so
I have a simple case here I'm having
issues
my bank I have been late on two payments
and I can't get in touch with anybody to
work on some kind of repayment plan I'll
be upset if this ends up hurting my
credit score so I'll run this so the top
of the right so I saying credit
reporting which is correct right that
sounds about right
the original case is there you have you
know the the the the information from
whom that was that that came from and
you have the the sentiment index Oh more
or less correct it's slightly negative
to to neutral and you have you know the
the word cloud says issues with the bank
and even the word late so after bad
after bad you know exactly what what
what the what the case is this becomes
way more useful if the case is very long
right because you'll see you'll really
see things pop out it says you know
topic is finance and I didn't I
purposely didn't put a bank name in
there so it's just says bank as the
organization so you know that's
acceptable here and then we see the
similar complaints right so there are
complaints that are extremely long and
what I like here is that it's not
pulling anything too large so we know
that there is some you know it is kind
of for now looking at not only the
similar words but also weighing it
correctly and we see you know everything
is related to a repayment plan so you
can't repay my loan can't repay my loan
dealing with my lender need information
about my loan are struggling to repay it
alone and you'll see you know this is
not helping you know it's going to I was
seeing you're worried about you know
that credit score being affected here it
is I like my picked one here late so I
mean they they're all related to to the
query in question right and they all
very different but they're similar right
so that's that's what that's what's
really interesting about this approach
and you know you can it's kind of like
there's word Tyvek and there's doctor
vac I don't know if you've heard of
these terms this is more paragraph to
vector a B will make it into a final
product where you can take a paragraph
and find a similar paragraph by adding
extra weighting by uttering all these
kind of things um so I'll close this by
saying to
things and from seeing the the people we
know raising their hands I think we're
all kind of on the same page there are
two things that are really uh that are
really great right now a natural
language processing - in my opinion I've
worked in natural language processing
for the past ten years and I've seen
such a progression to enormous boons to
- to our work is one is having access to
these pre trained word vectors right
this is huge
gilad is one there are tons of other
ones you have them for all major
languages and you'll have them for
specialized languages legal medical
people have gone through the painstaking
work of modeling huge corpuses of
different languages and made them
available have released them in the
public domain for us to work so I
encourage anybody who needs unless you
need really specialized rare dialects or
rare technical language use them it's
probably better than anything we can
come up with these are usually a PhD
students who work on it they do it
really well you know we should leverage
that work and it's there for us to use
the second so work perfect was actually
a big one right but the pre-trained word
vectors even better right because you
don't have to do it yourself and the
second thing that was really a real boon
to to natural language processing is for
a ceding language in - convolutional
neural networks like Korea talked about
it's you can CNN seem to do anything
these days time series natural language
processing along with you know images
and and and sound these kind of things
that it does normally it does it really
well and a huge advantage is a lot of
the feature engineering is done
automatically by the the neural network
you don't have to worry about it so it
you know and as we get better at this
it's gonna get a lot better than any
feature engineering we can come up with
us humans we do have a github it's not
currently open we're gonna we need to we
were focusing on getting this
presentation done we're gonna clean up
the code and then we'll we'll we'll
publish every one of these parts and
maybe like in three separate code bases
in in this github repository if you want
access please email us if you want
access before that please email us
there's also the the link to the demo is
there that also will be open for a bit
we may we may close it after a while and
you have the the link to spring ml and
Prius and my in my email address so you
know we you know if you have questions
about this it doesn't have to be
about case routing or anything natural
language processing or even anything
CNN's we'd love to help out we'd love to
get involved if your organization needs
help there we also be happy to get
involved so we're gonna open it up for
questions if there's any questions
please you can ask them and you know and
we'll be around afterwards as well
[Music]